ni siquiera la muerte pudo silenciarlo
en este taxi se oye la voz de Martínez
Soho
un reconocido presentador de radio
camerúnez que fue secuestrado y
asesinado en enero bajo circunstancias
que todavía no están claras
en la entrada de la emisora amplitud FM
donde trabajaba Martínez Soho sus
colegas mantienen un altar en su memoria
Todavía están conmocionados pero hacen
un esfuerzo por seguir al aire
esta mañana
dirige la reunión editorial del día que
empieza con un minuto de silencio por
Martínez Soco tres meses después de su
desaparición el equipo de amplitud FM
aún no se ha recuperado de la ausencia
de su presentador estrella
cuando salimos de nuestras casas y
llegamos a las instalaciones de la radio
lo primero que vemos es el altar que
está en la entrada
al verlo francamente nos dan ganas de
llorar
durante 12 años Martínez sobo fue el
presentador del programa en amplitud FM
una radio Privada de yaundé denunciaba
la corrupción y la malversación de
fondos de algunas figuras importantes en
el poder A veces lo señalaba
directamente por sus nombres a pesar de
su desaparición el programa con la voz
de sobo se ha mantenido al aire a la
espera de un nuevo presentador
la voz de Martínez Soco todavía se
escucha en este estudio entre las 9:30 y
las doce de la mañana
porque Tratamos de inmortalizar su alma
Y por eso decidimos volver a emitir sus
programas mientras Esperamos que se haga
justicia
su programa emputage se mantendrá el
concepto será casi igual pero
eventualmente tendremos otro presentador
la muerte de Martínez sobo provocó un
verdadero sismo en Camerún sacó a la luz
las amenazas contrainformantes y
periodistas que tratan temas sensibles
lo sabe por experiencia propia fue
secuestrado por unos desconocidos en
damás un barrio de la capital en marzo
de 2022 hacia las 10 de la noche aquí
estamos exactamente en el lugar donde me
secuestraron yo estaba saliendo de ahí
ellos llegaron me subieron a un vehículo
y nos fuimos como ven Todo estaba
organizado en el auto que lo llevó ese
día por la autopista encima que conduce
al aeropuerto sus captores lo amenazaron
de muerte por sus tomas de posición
apenas arrancamos me quitaron la ropa y
me taparon la cara me dijeron que
pusiera las manos detrás de la cabeza
y que mirara directamente al suelo casi
durante ocho kilómetros me golpeaban y
me decían que me iban a matar por ser
obstinado me dijeron que rezara por
última vez porque habían venido a
asesinarme En este terreno a un lado de
la carretera o secuestradores de pollo
tal lo torturaron y lo dejaron
abandonado después de darlo por muerto
me hicieron quitar los pantalones y me
dejaron totalmente desnudo como una
lombriz
me golpeaban por turnos con piedras
en un momento empecé a escupir sangre
hasta me hice el muerto pero no paraban
me desmayé
estuve tirado en el suelo unos 30
minutos en el otro extremo de la ciudad
nos encontramos con Cristóbal bobbiocono
director editorial del periódico calara
especializado en temas judiciales
el periódico se interesó particularmente
por las circunstancias del caso que
desembocó en el asesinato de Martínez
Soho el periodista estaba denunciando
una sospechas de malversación de fondos
que involucran a un hombre de negocios
cercano al poder y a un alto responsable
político Cameron es Cristóbal bobbiocono
dice que la muerte del periodista
despertó el miedo entre la redacciones
cameronesas
por la forma en la que trataron el
cuerpo de Martínez Soho con todas las
agresiones que recibió
parecía que hubieran dejado un mensaje
para los periodistas especialmente para
los que hablan de ciertos temas
Entonces nos sentimos aludidos
sabemos que tenemos el deber de informar
a nuestros compatriotas es nuestra
profesión es nuestra misión
lo Seguiremos haciendo pero en el fondo
sabemos que el peligro está ahí entre
tanto la investigación para aclarar las
circunstancias de la muerte de Martínez
sobo continúa los tres sospechosos
principales del caso están retenidos en
la cárcel central de yaunde
y de la cadena de televisión visión
cuatro y dos altos responsables del
servicio secreto camerúnez son acusados
de tortura un aspecto que preocupa al
abogado cloth asira
a todos nos sorprende que la acusación
no sea solo por tortura
porque hace pensar que la muerte fue
accidental pero evidentemente la muerte
era el objetivo
incluso queriendo darles el beneficio de
la duda habría sido mejor hacer una
acusación más general que incluyera todo
aunque al final se retiraran algunos
cargos
las condiciones de la acusación permiten
establecer que el proceso no es
transparente de acuerdo con el más
reciente informe de reporteros Sin
fronteras Camerún ocupa el puesto 118 de
180 en el índice de libertad de prensa
según la organización Cameron sigue
siendo uno de los países más peligrosos
de África